of the people is a new platform matching
local campaigns with supporters and
donors from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out
at of the people.us one of the stories
we've been talking about now
uh really for the last five years since
the trump era started but even
in particular in the context of the
january sixth riots which are sort of
like the culmination
of a peak of complete non-thinking
anti-intellectual
radical violent extremism the question
we've been thinking about is
sort of like how far back does this go
when did this start to infect the
american right wing and there are people
who
wrongly believe either that donald trump
created this extremism and that's that's
definitely
not true um or that the extremism
started in the last five to ten years
and donald trump merely coalesced it
which is
like five percent closer to the truth
but but still very much
not accurate and james rosen wrote a
really interesting piece in the hartford
current
called republican embrace of extremism
began long before trump and you can read
about it and
in the the piece james rosen actually
goes back to
talking about 1994 and newt gingrich as
a congressman at the time
uh becoming speaker of the house and how
that was sort of a seminal moment
in the radicalization of the republican
party and i think
to a great extent that's true but
the stage was actually set even before
that
and would go back i would say to the
1980s and ronald reagan
and you don't see the same i mean listen
there's no doubt that lauren bobert
marjorie taylor green
trumpian radicalism stormed the capital
and this type of stuff
that was not around in the 80s and that
was not even around
in the in the mid 90s when newt gingrich
took over but it's a progression and
this is why i've been arguing that it's
going to take
realistically a decade
maybe decades i don't know i mean maybe
eight to ten years minimum to make a big
dent in this
because it's been building for so long
and we've interviewed like over the last
over the last eight years i've
interviewed people on all aspects of
this
conspiracism anti-intellectualism
religious radicalization cult-like
mentality
educational issues that lead to people
being susceptible to this stuff
lack of media literacy all of these
different things
are sort of charted parallel to the
political story that is that has taken
over
on the american right and if you really
want to you could go back to the civil
rights era
you could actually go back to late 50s
60s civil rights era
and roe v wade era where i
i don't know i i it's almost like when
you get to 60 years it starts to become
harder to tell the story in discrete
steps but you could even say it started
then but certainly in the 80s
with reaganomics and the start of the
spread
of in the more academic side
supply side economics but the way that
that
infected many on the right with these
sort of faux libertarian ideas that
become very authoritarian when the
outcomes are not what they want
stories about welfare queens a
free riders on insurance social welfare
and insurance plans and this type of
thing
in the 80s that primed the pump
for newt gingrich to come in in 1994
and go to the next level and newt
gingrich in 94
certainly starts to make the republican
party look more
like the radicalism we see now this led
to
the impeachment of bill clinton and and
very
similar sort of persecution type
radicalism from the right
this then combined with continued
anti-intellectualism to give us george w
bush and remember that the non-thinking
right of today
blows the non-thinking right of the bush
era out of the water
but bush was really the guy that started
this oh this guy's kind of dim
sort of stuff where we said you know a
lot of these people really aren't
thinking
and they are being manipulated by
religious ideology they're being
manipulated by misunderstandings about
not only cultural
but also economic issues the idea of
education as
right as left-wing indoctrination uh
started to grow
then you get obama and obama as the
first black president a half-black
man started to take the
anti-intellectualism
and the radicalism and the
misunderstanding of economics and the
lack of media literacy
and coalesce it with
racism that still then was sort of
beneath the surface although it was
coming out
the number of death threats against
barack obama
birtherism etc so by then it was it was
really starting to bubble up and look
like the modern thing
and then comes trump and re like think
back at this point right
we go back to roe v wade and the start
of radicalization of the more religious
right
you go to the civil rights era and you
start with the radicalization
of the more overtly racist you get to
the 80s and you add
unthinking reaganomics and then you
gingrich comes in in 94 and gets us the
next step and then bush and then the
racism under obama and then in comes
trump
and trump really doesn't have to do much
at that point other than to make people
feel
good or comfortable going public with
all of this stuff that is built up
comes down the escalator as he says and
talks about
mexican rapists and some i'm sure are
good people s whole countries
making fun of a you know dis person with
a disability all of this different stuff
and then it just explodes so it's
actually notable and i encourage you to
read
uh the the piece in by james rosen in
the hartford current
it's actually notable when you look at
it how
little trump had to do with the
radicalization itself
but how perfectly timed he was to just
drop in and coalesce it now the
republican party remember didn't want
trump at the beginning
they wanted they wanted the
radicalization but they wanted it to
happen with someone that's more polished
like a mitt romney
remember the evangelical grifters who in
2012 were saying
romney's the chosen guy some of them
ended up like mike
mike lindell from my pillow believe
trump is the the chosen by god guy
so the republicans did want this type of
radicalization they believe it's good
for fundraising they believe it's good
electorally but they wanted it with
someone more polished like a mitt romney
we kind of forget about that because
romney and romney lost and trump
trump won and early on the republican
party didn't want trump eventually he
was able to commandeer the party
he said a lot of the quiet parts that
were sort of quiet under obama
although increasingly less so out loud
and the establishment people
early thought trump was destructive to
the party trump was bad to the party
but they eventually got you know they
acquiesced now they were right that it
was bad because ultimately the
republicans lost the house in 2018
and the senate in 2020 and the white
house in 2020 but the main
takeaway is that republicans embraced
extremism well before donald trump
there is a very notable double standard
that is taking place
as we predicted between the donald trump
sexual assault allegations and what's
going on with andrew cuomo now i want to
remind everybody
i don't care about political party
when it was anthony weiner i said look
at what this guy
this guy's accused of terrible things i
have nothing to say in defense of him
it's a shame in that he had some good
political ideas but how am i going to
defend this guy
with al franken i thought the
resignation happened too soon in
retrospect it definitely
happened too soon and it happened too
soon in part because democrats
too quickly started saying he should
resign what you know what al franken
the crass joke al franken was involved
in was not
good but compared to the things that
that we've seen since with trump and
others
it seems relatively milk toast without
dismissing
anyone's experience of what happened
with al franken
but i had no interest i i don't care
about party and much like with the
andrew cuomo thing
it's the same thing people have been
writing saying david why won't you cover
the andrew cuomo scandals i've covered
every aspect of it
i've covered the nursing home piece i've
covered the sexual assault piece
i i've covered every single aspect of it
and i don't care that he's a democrat
let the cards fall where they may
i i'm not uh impressed with politicians
in terms of personality cult of
personality and and deifying
what i don't i don't care about andrew
cuomo if if he did stuff wrong then
there should be consequences
but it is incredibly brazen
to now see so many on the right
including don jr himself who's appearing
on
a nighttime right-wing media several
times a week to talk about
accusers of andrew cuomo these same
people
including of course don jr were saying
nothing when trump was accused by a
dozen women
and then a second dozen and then what's
the total number 40 46
48 50 women or something like that max
boot who is
not someone who i go to for political
analysis
actually has a pretty good piece about
this in the washington post
called the andrew cuomo scandal
highlights republicans appalling double
standard
and he points out that the calls
for andrew cuomo to resign
from people who said nothing about the
allegations against donald trump or said
that they were not credible and
shouldn't be believed and they should be
ignored
is crazy and again max boot points out
democrats aren't giving andrew cuomo a
free
pass the new york times was
integral in unveiling the sexual
harassment scandal
related to andrew cuomo this is the new
york times
that trump and other republicans have
been saying for years is some kind of
far-left
protector of all democrats and
you you again see the huge double
standard it's a double standard i've
been pointing out for a long time what
democrats were defending
uh anthony weiner what democrats were
if anything the criticism of democrats
is in order to
show how they are going to go after
whoever is accused very quickly
sometimes they go too far and arguably
things went too far in the early calls
for al franken's
resignation which took place now i know
a lot of people are going to write in
and say
what what about tara reid the woman who
who accused joe biden
um that received a ton of coverage
and it started to fall apart and
eventually
the story went away i i don't i know
that there are people who are
not going to like that characterization
and are going to say no no it went away
because it was suppressed
that's not what i believe took place at
all i think it got plenty of coverage in
fact
so i say investigate everyone get
whoever out
i don't care about political party um
but what we are continuing to see is
exactly the type of hypocrisy on this
issue
you know the the that we've seen from
the right for a long time
you could you could argue it goes all
the way back to bill clinton you could
argue it goes back even further than
that i mean listen we were talking about
newt gingrich earlier
newt gingrich's past when it comes to
um relationships is not exactly what the
evangelical right
claims that they support or want to get
behind so this this has decades of
history behind it and the the hypocrisy
is
is stunning um let me know what you
think if i'm missing something
in this uh where i misunder i am seeing
hypocrisy where there is none or or
whatever
i certainly want to hear from you
remember that friday march 26th
we are doing a massive one day
membership special we had i'm almost
getting
emotional actually i just kind of choked
but it it plays well
february was a disastrous month for us
as far as memberships go
the continued economic pressure of the
virus combined with a short month
leading to many cancellations and few
subscriptions so on
friday the 26th we are doing a massive
membership discount to try to
get 2021 going for lack of a better term
if you want to be notified about that
membership special
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and uh
friday the 26th in the morning you will
get a perfect email telling you exactly
what to do
to avail yourself of this membership
discount
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
i recently mentioned our partnership
with the youtube channel nerds
for humanity and the team behind
that channel has built a new website
called of the people
which you can find at of the people.us
and they're one of our sponsors today
fascinating website
basically like a yelp for local
political candidates you can browse
and search for candidates based on
policy
location and background the key insight
from of the people
is that all national politics starts
local and by making it easier to
discover and support
everyday folks running for city council
or state assembly
county commissioner in your community
you can help
incubate the talent that will become
future
congressional representatives senators
even presidents
if you're a candidate running for local
office set up a profile
on otp it's free and you can attract
exposure and donors
and everyone else go support this
grassroots platform i put a link
underneath this video
and while you're at it don't forget to
subscribe to the nerds for humanity
youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our program is mostly funded by
memberships
you can get one at joinpakman.com i have
some
delightful video for you today
congresswoman katie porter has really
become
very very good at humiliating
um uh uh people who seem to think she's
clueless people who go in to testify
before
congress and apparently think that
they're going to be able to get one over
on her
when they are not because she's not only
extremely knowledgeable on all issues
financial and business
but extraordinarily well prepared and
there was a subcommittee hearing
yesterday
called modernizing energy development
laws
for the benefit of taxpayers communities
in the environment it's a mouthful
one of the people who was testifying was
mark
murphy the president of the strata
production company
in roswell new mexico this is an oil and
gas
company it's not a huge company they
have 16 employees
and generate according to a report about
two and a half million dollars in sale
so it's not a massive company but not
particularly relevant today
and in an exchange with katie porter
murphy tries to claim
there's no special tax rules for oil and
gas
if we have expenses we get to deduct
expenses like any other business
trying to suggest there aren't special
rules
that apply to oil and gas that don't
apply
to a mom-and-pop hardware store or a
taco stand or whatever the case may be
it's not true and katie porter knew it
and she wasn't going to let it slip take
a look
they're estimated to be between 60 to
90 of the costs of drilling how much of
those intangible drilling costs do you
get to deduct right away from your taxes
um we get to deduct all of those just
like any other business
uh we do not excuse me there seems to be
a misconception out there that you're
operating from
that somehow the oil and gas industry
benefits from some special
sort of tax structure we don't we
actually
we actually reclaiming my time mr murphy
i will follow up with you mr murphy but
you do benefit from special rules
there's a special tax rule
for intangible drilling costs that does
not apply
to other kinds of expenses that
businesses have you get to deduct 70
of your costs immediately and other
businesses have to amortize their
expenses
over their entire profit stream we we
also please don't
please don't patronize me by telling me
that the oil and gas industry
doesn't have any special tax provisions
because if you would like that to be the
rule i would be happy to have congress
deliver i yield back
so it actually goes way beyond just this
the the truth is that there are many tax
benefits available for oil and gas
investors
that aren't available elsewhere in the
tax code for other types of businesses
and some of them are
sort of relatively not not so much
esoteric but because they only apply to
to a very narrow scope of business
a lot of people aren't aware of them the
two largest
subsidies for oil and gas are
something called excess of percentage
over cost
depletion and the expensing of
exploration
and development costs these add up to
billions in subsidies for companies like
mark murphy's
and when we talk about excess of
percentage over cost depletion what this
allows producers uh harvesters
of oil and gas to do is deduct
a fixed percentage of gross revenue as a
capital expense each year
regardless of whether they actually had
that capital expense or not
so when you the the way that you would
you would typically
deduct costs is you deduct real costs
you uh have you know a million dollars
in revenue
and a hundred thousand dollars in costs
and you deduct the hundred thousand
dollars in real costs
this special rule for oil and gas
allows producers like mark murphy's
company
to deduct 15 of gross revenue
for what's called resource depletion
regardless of whether they actually
incurred that as an amount of cost you
just chop
15 right off the top you made 10 million
you get to deduct 1.5 million 15 percent
because you are depleting your source of
oil and gas you get a benefit
from the very depletion of a resource
which you are executing what that is a
specific benefit for oil and gas
intangible
drilling costs which include everything
but
actual drilling equipment so when you
when you do drilling
there's labor there's chemicals there's
grease there's all sorts of other stuff
that are considered
intangible these expenses normally are
60 to 80 percent of the total cost of
drilling a well
and they are 100 deductible in the year
incurred
so if it costs three hundred thousand
dollars to drill a well
and we say well of that three hundred
thousand seventy five percent is
intangible
the investor gets a deduction
right away of the full amount even if
you
don't produce oil even if you don't
strike oil as long as you started to
operate that
facility by the 31st of march of the
following year
you get to deduct all this stuff
regardless of what's actually happening
most businesses don't get to do that oil
and gas also get
accelerated depreciation of
infrastructure
and they also get an exemption on
alternative minimum tax and i know we're
getting sort of like wonky and deep here
there's something called alternative
minimum tax the point of alternative
minimum tax
is to avoid people from being able to
deduct
all the way down to owing nothing so at
higher
incomes imagine you make five million
dollars
you might be able to by combining
accelerated depreciation
intangible uh uh deductions all this
different stuff you might be able to say
hey you know what
i have an adjusted income of only a
million dollars even though there was a
five million dollars that came in
i've got all these different deductions
i get down to a million dollars the
point of alternative minimum tax is to
say
you can't deduct yourself below a
certain level of taxable income
the tax law specifically exempts
those intangible drilling costs from
alternative minimum tax so regardless
of your amt you can always
continue to deduct out those intangible
drilling costs
that's a gift to oil and gas so
nice job by katie porter pointing out
that there
are special exceptions made for oil and
gas that don't apply to other businesses
and i could go on with even more of
these there are actually a ton of them
and the the whole point the oil and gas
industry doesn't want you to know about
these
because if you did you might be outraged
as you should be something really
strange is happening at white house
press briefings
lately it's almost like reporters
don't have any idea what to ask about
and i don't want to suggest that there
is nothing to ask about
as i've talked about for weeks now joe
biden's failed executive order on
stopping deportations
foreign policy questions minimum wage
there are plenty of things to ask about
during jen saki's white house press
briefings
but for some reason reporters at press
briefings
are increasingly concerned with asking
over and over and over again why won't
you call the situation at the border
a crisis which is just this endlessly
semantic
question and yesterday questions about
joe biden's dogs and possibly a cat
it i'm not joking joe biden's younger
dog
major biden bit someone at the white
house the person
is fine as of yesterday it wasn't
totally clear
who it was as of today it seems that it
was a secret service agent
it was reported that major biden was
sort of surprised as a secret service
agent came around the corner something
like that had a minor injury treated at
the white house
now after one reporter had already asked
about it yesterday another reporter
asks a follow-up and the question is
phrased
in a wacky histrionic dramatic way
asking whether gen saki can assure the
american public
that major biden isn't going to be
euthanized look at this
about three things that's okay the dogs
immigration and then governor
another dog's question okay go ahead
just a quick clarification on the dogs
okay can you confirm that it was a
secret service member who was bitten
and can you also reassure the public
that major biden will not be euthanized
as a result of this
well certainly major biden is a member
of the family so i can assure you that
i don't have any more details on the
individual i would encourage you to ask
the secret service but i'm not going to
have any more
details other than that it's all phrased
in the most histrionic and dramatic
terms possible
jen can you assure the public as if the
public is waiting around to know this
that major won't be euthanized if you
have to ask
a second question about joe biden's dogs
maybe it would be
has the biden family determined how they
will handle major biden in the future in
light of this dog bite like if you if
you are going to insist on asking more
about it
but can you reassure us he won't be
euthanized
just desperate to create controversy
if she had said i have no idea whether
they're going to euthanize the dog
i haven't spoken to joe biden about it
then the headline would be
gen saki refuses to deny that joe that
major biden might be
euthanized and then i guess at some
point someone in the past said maybe the
bidens will be getting a cat
and another reporter asking about the
cat
if you can imagine questions we've heard
all about dogs we were promised a white
house cat
what happened to that where is the cat
today's a good day for the cat
i don't have any update on the cat we
know the cat will break the internet
but i don't have any update on its
status so there it is literally
devolving into questions about dogs and
cats
and i think part of what's going on here
part is
the reporters don't don't know what to
ask about substantively
part of it is that we are now moving
beyond the reality tv presidency of
donald trump
joe biden isn't tweeting attacks at
people all day long joe biden's
administration isn't denouncing the
press as an institution
and it's sort of like reporters are
struggling to move beyond the reality
show
that was the trump presidency my
question to you is do you think they
don't know what to ask or do they think
that these
questions will be seen as relevant and
interesting by the american people i
just don't even understand the
motivation to ask about a cat
maybe don't ask a question if you have
nothing relevant to ask about maybe
that's part of it where
if you're in the briefing room even if
you have nothing to say
you want to get a question in there and
so you ask about a cat
i really don't have the explanation as
to what's going on but i'd be curious to
hear from you
and we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show
instagram page find us on instagram at
david pakman show
find me on instagram at david.pack
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world-famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial-free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with
naomi klein who is senior correspondent
at the intercept and also
author of how to change everything naomi
great to have you on today
happy to be with you i i've been
engaging in this conversation with many
in my audience
about how we sort of make progress on a
lot of
of different issues that come down to
what people know and what people believe
certainly climate change would be on
that list at a more micro
level you know even beliefs about what
happened in the november of 2020
election would count
uh beliefs about how vaccines work
beliefs about the the messages we get
from the cdc and others
and i believe that there's really no
simple fix here i
think that this is probably a
multi-generational project
folks have been sort of indoctrinated
into many of the orthodoxies that now
plague us
starting i would argue going back to the
reagan era
with stories of welfare queens and and
and so on and so forth
is i'm curious as to the reason for for
sort of um
writing this book to be accessible to
younger readers is it at least partially
an acknowledgement of of the
the the battle we're up against here
that will be quite a long battle
uh that's an interesting question um
you know i didn't think about it in that
way of like
get em while they're young i i really
wrote the book
directed at at young readers because
this book is
it's my first book that is uh um for
young readers it's
it's really geared towards like um
middle school
and early high school and it's really
because
this is where the energy of the climate
movement is right now i
you know i was on the board of 350.org
for a decade
and was part of kicking off the fossil
fuel divestment movement which was very
much
university age students and
and and those you know university age
students are still
involved in all kinds of activism as you
know but
the energy of the climate movement is
now coming from
younger than that it's it's like greta
it's the greta generation
um and so and so that's why
i wanted to write a book for this kind
of i see a real generational shift and i
wanted to
arm those young people with the facts
and figures
to um you know to to to make them better
activists and
and to keep them in this in the struggle
for the long term
yeah you seem to go at what are frequent
misconceptions among adults i mean i
think what's interesting is that
the issues you're addressing aren't
particularly different
because the audience is younger it's
just eventually folks with
misunderstandings get older and then
they become adults with a lot of a lot
of the same misunderstandings
as an example you go at this idea of
climate change isn't just
it's warmer everywhere all the time
we're talking about
there could be a warming over all of the
oceans with erratically hot
and cold weather the way we've seen in
texas and in other places
the issues seem to be quite similar as
if you were addressing an adult
adult audience yeah look the information
in this book is
not um substantively different
than than the information in books i've
written for
for older readers it's
not dumbed down it's just kind of
simplified and a lot of people
told me that they think that the book
would be actually suitable for adults
that they know
which may well be true and i'm not going
to comment on that i mean because we
didn't dumb it down we just kind of
pared it down
simplified it and the fact is you know
the first book i wrote about climate
change this changes everything
has 70 pages of endnotes i mean it's
really like um it's just very backed up
and it's really about bringing the
receipts
and proving and re-proving because when
that book was published in 2014
um making the argument that it's sort of
the
core drivers of capitalism and
neoliberal the neoliberal project that
are at the root of why we failed
to address this crisis was treated as a
really really radical
idea and so i really needed to back it
up but i think that
having a more sort of simplified
handbook can be helpful for
for people of all ages but one one point
i would want to make about when you were
just bringing up at the start
around um you know
around around this multi-generational
project
i would say that there's some really
interesting research that shows
that the most effective communicators
at changing minds are
the young are the daughters of climate
change
deniers that or or people who believe
that
you know okay it's real but there's
nothing that we can do
um rather than hearing you know somebody
on television
lecture them um what what the research
finds actually
is that parents are being swayed by
their kids their kids are pushing them
around the dinner table and saying what
are you doing about this
i'm really frightened i want something
different um
so it turns out that that when we reach
kids we actually do reach their parents
we've we've all seen stories of a
lifelong typically republican elected
official
who had homophobic beliefs for a long
time
and then it turns out that you know they
have an lgbt
uh child in their family or nephew or
something like that
and they ultimately revisit their
beliefs and they they come out with a
different view and and that's that's
sort of good
at the maybe what we would call the
retail level but
depending on everyone having like a
personal experience could be difficult
if that's what we're counting on
i'm wondering how this would apply to
climate change where
to some degree does the cultural shift
need the repercussions to be more real
and tangible to individuals before they
may be
fully willing to to consider they may
have been led astray on this issue
well the first thing i would just say is
that
people are already experiencing the
impacts of climate change
yeah and this is very very widespread
um and so i think
it's important to clearly explain how
something like what just happened in
texas um
may well be linked with uh warming
destabilized climate
certainly the wildfires that people are
living with every summer in the pacific
northwest
is definitely linked to climate change
certainly more ferocious summer storms
are linked to warming oceans um so we
need to be making those arguments and it
isn't like i just want to be clear that
that it's not like oh we have to wait
till things get really bad and then
people will understand this is real
things are bad
things are really bad um and we need to
make those arguments we need to make
those connections
um yeah so um and in terms of i mean i
guess your thoughts about the
cultural change that that because with a
lot of these things it as we know
it's not about hammering facts
necessarily
so i guess the other thing i would just
i would just emphasize
this just my perspective i feel like
some of your questions are coming from
you are emphasizing what i would
describe as the hard deniers right
kind of like the hardest to reach kind
of
fox news addicted uh um
you know it's all a chinese hoax like
really really dug
in right climate change deniers and
um i actually don't spend a ton of time
thinking about
how to reach the hardest to reach i
think that there's
um more productive work to be done in
in what sometimes described as the soft
climate deniers or people who
actually don't deny the reality of
climate change at all
believe it is happening but what they
believe is that we're too we're too far
gone
um it's human nature and we're all we're
never gonna really care
think about the future kind of climate
doomers more than climate deniers
um and i think we actually make a
mistake
by over emphasizing reaching the hardest
to reach most dug in most
invested in that denial mindset while
ignoring
a much easier to reach middle middle
terrain
of people who know it's happening but
feel kind of hopeless about doing
anything about it right that's
interesting
yeah if we if we do a good job if we do
a good job of reaching
the soft deniers do the hard deniers
even matter as much
they matter much much less because in
fact what the polling shows is that a
majority
of americans know that climate change is
happening a lot of people think it's too
late
a lot of people think have bought the
idea that
you have to choose between good jobs and
acting on climate
so there's a ton of work to be done uh
working with trade unions organizing
workers in different sectors
and um and and really
designing a future that people are
willing to fight for right that's what a
green new deal is about
um and breaking that's a false dichotomy
between job
job choosing between jobs and caring
about the environment that
i think is very productive how do you
suggest
approaching those who maybe are in that
that middle group where
they acknowledge that it's happening
they probably even acknowledge that
at least some part of it is because of
human activity if if not all
but they don't like what they believe to
be the solutions which might in their
minds include we might not be able to
have cars anymore we'd be restricted on
travel
we might have to keep our houses at 55
degrees in the you know
that they don't like what they believe
the lifestyle implications are
right and they believe that because
they've been lied to right and they
believe that because there's been a very
systematic campaign
to um you know latch onto a throwaway
calm
joke that aoc made about banning cow
farts to claim that they're gonna
come seize your the cattle you know uh
um
and and and ban airlines forever things
like that
yeah um that's been a deliberate
campaign to scare people
um and so uh you know i
you know i think a a lot of these
arguments are not going to be one with
arguments they're going to be
one with facts they're going to be one
with with with people's lived
experiences and this is where i think
that it's
useful to think about
some of fdr's strategies in rolling out
the original new deal right the green
new deal is
is modeled um after
and you know it's not it's not an
imitation it's also
it's also a corrective in lots of
ways and problems with the original new
deal but it's inspired by the original
new deal
in this scale in the mobilization in the
idea that we need a mission right
the original new deal was not a narrow
poverty alleviation program in the
middle of the great depression it was a
new governing framework that affected
every aspect of life right it was dozens
and dozens of policies
and that's the kind of ambition that we
need in the face of a crisis that
touches every part of our lives right
the reason we get overwhelmed in the
face of the climate crisis
is because we know that it isn't going
to be solved by
you know changing our light bulbs like
we were told for a couple of decades
right i mean it affects every aspect of
our lives and we've
never had a policy framework on the
scale of the crisis that we face
um so coming back to fdr
he was very smart um in in where he
cited a new deal projects like if you
map
where uh fdr planted
uh ccc projects for instance the
civilian conservation corps which is
responsible for around 800 state parks
planted
more than 2 billion trees employed
around 3 million young people
he deliberately cited those ccc camps
in the parts of the country that voted
against him and if you look at the
election results in 1936
he flipped many of those red rural areas
blue
and he and they didn't do it with
arguments they did it with you know
facts on the ground they did it with the
this is services that are improving your
community
improving daily life creating jobs and
people
saw it um and they liked it and they
wanted more
and so i think that this is this should
be a
challenge for the democrats you know
they have
lost rural america and we can't
write off rural america we need to
invest
and it isn't going to be about having
the perfect argument
and the perfect messaging it's going to
be about
what is this huge green infrastructure
program going to look like who's going
to benefit from it
how how is that going to be messaged
once it's being rolled out
um and that is way more important than
some abstract debate that we could have
about no no no it's not going to kill
jobs no show people the jobs
change people's daily lives for the
better yeah along those lines i mean i'd
love to
kind of wrap our conversation talking
legislatively we know joe biden
does not support the green new deal but
took many elements from it in putting
together
what what his proposal was before he was
elected and of course
we will now see if after this coveted
relief bill is done
whether that is very high on the list of
priorities and sort of what happens
do you think that if it if it doesn't
happen during these two years during
which democrats know they control the
house senate and white house
that it really becomes a question mark
as to if and when it happens i mean do
you think it's urgent that it be done
not just from the scientific standpoint
where obviously it's urgent
but politically as well yeah
it's urgent on both fronts right that
this is our window we are now in what we
call the decade of the green new deal
right um and and frankly i don't really
care about the branding of it
you know you want to call it buildback
better i don't care what matters is that
it's guided by science and justice
um and and and as long as those core
principles are there
uh that we are staying within our carbon
budget of keeping temperature warming
below 1.5
degrees celsius doing everything we
possibly can and i don't care what you
call it you know if
40 uh of of the green infrastructure
is actually going to be for frontline
communities of color
uh based on core environmental justice
principles i don't care what you call it
right
because you're taking the core ideas
behind uh the green new deal
and behind the just transition i mean
the truth is these ideas have gone by
many names over the years you know when
i wrote this changes everything i
started it with a quote from a bolivian
climate change negotiator who called for
a martial plan for planet earth
that's what they called it in 2009 you
know uh we've called it the leap
in canada i don't care what you call it
i care what we
do and we have two years you're
absolutely right
we have two years to convince people um
with their lived experience not convince
people on television convince people
with their lived
experience and communicating the ideas
and the reality behind these policies
because we we just can't lose any more
time we have lost
decades talking and not acting yep
scientifically environmentally and
and politically urgent i think uh we we
would certainly agree
the book is how to change everything and
naomi klein the book's author is
senior correspondent for the intercept
so great having you on today
thank you it's been a pleasure take care
bye david
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of the oldest most tired and
unsophisticated tropes of the american
right wing is calling anything nuanced
anything intellectual even simply
something science-based
gay or sometimes they'll use the code
word effeminate if they're a little
slicker
like fox news propagandist tucker
carlson and
indeed last night tucker carlson did a
commentary about this entire pandemic
and it was sort of a rant about how all
these doctor doctors and experts telling
us what to do
uh aren't the people that we should be
following and that there's something
sort of not
masculine in fact about following people
like dr fauci
and tucker devolves into the basis of
base arguments
which is that listening to public health
experts like dr
fauci makes one delicate timid
and effeminate which are just
sophisticated words
for the right wing to say oh that's gay
man that's really gay
and of course tucker hides this by
saying this is the view
of some chinese adviser to the
government why tucker cares
what a chinese advisor would say when
typically tucker is denouncing
the chinese communist party i don't know
but here it's convenient
and tucker says look the advisor says
that it's a masculinity crisis it's
effeminate to do this stuff and
it's sort of like when we listen to dr
fauci take a listen to this
well this tells you everything in march
of last year the leadership of the
united states and of china
both declared national emergencies in
the u.s tony fauci warned congress that
reopening american businesses could
cause coronavirus outbreaks the
government may not be able to control
going outside tony fauci said was just
too risky
meanwhile in china where the coronavirus
originated a top
advisor to the chinese government
declared that the country was
experiencing a very different kind of
threat a more profound threat
the problem he said was a national
masculinity crisis
chinese boys quote have been spoiled by
housewives and female teachers
and they were becoming as a result quote
delicate timid and effeminate
in essence they were becoming people who
might listen to someone like tony fauci
left unchecked said the chinese
government advisor
the feminization of chinese boys would
quote inevitably endanger the survival
and development of the chinese nation
did you see how tucker did that he
doesn't use the word
gay and he doesn't say it's his idea
but then he says it's sort of like
listening to dr
fauci the chinese doctor saying we've
become
delicate timid and effeminate that's
sort of like when we listen to dr fauci
when dr fauci as a doctor explains how
viruses work and suggests what people
should do
if you listen to that it's sort of gay
that's that's the code language
that is being used here this is just red
meat for the right it's another version
of the real men don't go to the doctor
type of
sort of troglodytic thinking now
maybe natural selection prefers
effeminate timid and delicate i don't
know
i guess we'll see who survives this
thing but they're not even
trying to hide their contempt and
resentment
for anybody who listens to actual
experts rather than fox news so-called
experts
now you really have to think about what
the end game is here because it strikes
me as a logical and what i mean by that
is fox news's audience is
disproportionately
older folks who we know are more at risk
of dying from coronavirus
if fox news's audience followed the
advice of fox news hosts for the last
year
many of them would be dying when they
didn't have to die fox news would be
essentially killing off its own audience
and it makes no sense in that context
so the end game can't possibly be that
but it's all part of the political
movement
that pushed the anti-mass protests for
freedom
promoted donald trump's radiologist dr
scott atlas's views on a communicable
disease completely outside of his area
of expertise
generally promoted ignoring science on
just about every aspect of the pandemic
and it's amazing how much things change
and yet
how much things stay the same so much
has changed in society and culture
since when i was in school in the 90s
and it was common to say oh that's gay
and yet tucker carlson a 51 year old man
in 2021
is going right back to that same trope
now one last thought just as an aside
is tucker carlson now the image of right
wing masculinity
and i asked that in a serious way i
don't care how tucker looks i care
about what tucker says but is it now
is this the image that republicans now
consider the pinnacle of masculinity a
bow tie wearing
sort of high-pitched voice country club
guy maybe it is i don't know and i don't
care what tucker looks like
or what he sounds like i care about what
he says but it's also kind of weird to
me that
he's talking about it's effeminate to
listen to doctors
when i don't recognize tucker as the
image of right-wing masculinity that's
sort of bandied about
at the motorcycle rallies and the
shooting ranges i don't know
now just one more thing tucker in the
opening
also said going outside
is too risky according to dr fauci
i looked and looked and couldn't find
any instances throughout this pandemic
of dr fauci saying stay in your homes
i i just couldn't find it so it seems
that also even on the premise even on
the facts tucker carlson is not
surprisingly
completely wrong again hey this is sort
of becoming a more interesting news
story to me now as many of you know
we did not cover the meghan markle
prince harry interview with oprah on the
podcast or on the broadcast show
we did talk about why these stories do
well
on yesterday's bonus show but we didn't
talk about the actual interview on on
the broadcast show just it didn't really
seem like a story
for our show there's now kind of like an
ancillary or a tangential media story
which is developed around this which is
that british uh uh journalist and tv
personality piers morgan
who at one point actually had a nightly
show in the united states
stormed off the set of good morning
britain yesterday and then subsequently
quit or was fired it's one of those
situations where we
we don't know i had no idea of the full
backstory on this
and it's it's quite interesting in how
thin skinned
piers appears to be apparently piers
morgan has been displeased with meghan
markle
the duchess of sussex for a long time
and part of it might be that he tried to
date her
and she wasn't interested check out this
video where he explains that
they went on what what i i'm hearing
described as a date
and then she ghosted him take a look we
had a
two hours in the pub she had a couple of
dirty martinis and a couple of pints we
got them brilliantly
and then i put her in a cab and it
turned out to be a cab
that took her to a party where she met
prince harry and then the next night
they had a solo dinner together
and that was the last i ever heard from
meghan markle
and i have never heard from her again so
what happened
she ghosted me ryan meghan markle
ghosted
did she do you think she just went i'm
afraid
i really liked it this is why it hurts i
i really liked her so this almost
appears to be a personal thing for peers
based on that and this unbeknownst to me
until i learned about all of it
has led to peers making lots of negative
comments about meghan markle over the
years again i don't follow this stuff i
learned all of it in the last 24 hours
so then over the last couple of days
piers has continued to attack megan
saying that her claims about british
royal family being concerned about
her son's skin color is completely
fabricated
that the british royal family isn't
racist that meghan markle is lying
pier's just defending the royals and
attacking meghan markle
yesterday on good morning britain his
co-host
alex beresford essentially said piers
what you've been saying is disgusting
and piers morgan literally walks off the
set take a look
and i understand that you don't like
meghan markle you've made it so clear a
number of times on this program a number
of times
and i understand that you've got a
personal relationship
with mega market or had one and she cut
you off
she's entitled to cut you off if she
wants to
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue
to trash her okay i'm done with this no
to sit there and listen 6 30 to 7
o'clock yesterday
was incredibly hard to watch so piers
morgan walking off there
and then subsequently after this episode
yesterday
it was abruptly announced by itv that
piers morgan
is departing good morning britain the
official statement is that quote
following discussions
with itv piers morgan has decided now is
the time to leave now the wording
doesn't tell us
whether piers morgan decided that
because he was told by itv
you should decide that it's time to
leave we don't know we may never know
for me the worst part of all of this and
what makes me want to talk about it
is that piers morgan on monday said he
doesn't believe
meghan markle was truly suicidal one of
the things that came up during the
interview with oprah winfrey
that was revealed by meghan markle was
that she she was having suicidal
thoughts
i really don't care about the royal
family as you know it's not something we
cover
other than to say that it's an
antiquated apparatus and institution
my concerns are journalistic ethics harm
reduction people's health
media ethics and this type of thing we
are in a mental health crisis
exacerbated by the pandemic with so much
stigma
around seeking treatment and such lack
of access to mental health treatment in
the united states and in many other
countries
and someone notable publicly saying i
was suicidal i was thinking of taking my
own life
and then someone as prominent as piers
morgan says i doubt whether that's
really true i think she might have been
making it up
that's a disaster and it's dangerous and
it could actually lead to more suicide
now i don't care about pierce
he's wealthy he'll find other jobs he'll
be fine in all ways
but fundamentally he's always struck me
as an insecure guy there's instances of
him making fun of reality show
contestants in ways that
seem to kind of go beyond what would be
normal just for entertainment
but this is is really just beyond the
pale
and it all kind of falling apart before
our very eyes in the last
24 hours and uh the the risk is
that by casting doubt onto you know we
know that
for example we know that one reason that
rape accusers sometimes don't come
forward
is fear that they won't be believed and
um much the same way pearce
saying he doubts the truth of whether
someone claiming to have been suicidal
uh was really suicidal that's only going
to encourage people who need help not to
seek it
and it could have disastrous
consequences so that's that's the most
vile and disgusting aspect of this
i'm interested also in hearing from you
what your thoughts are about the entire
fiasco
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192
david p here is a voicemail i received
from a nurse about
covid and vitamin d an important topic
let's take a listen your bonus show
dated march the 9th and you're talking
about covet cases
and the obesity 77
those cases with uh
severe morbid obesity um i'm a dietitian
practicing in st
louis in the critical illness recovery
hospital where we specialize in
okay so dietitian not nurse just to
correct that weaning
patients off of ventilators and i do
nutrition support
and one of the things that you were
touching upon was vitamin d
and i have been
doing investigation on my own
and every single patient that we have
had
had been tested for vitamin d deficiency
with an alarming
amount of those people having deficiency
and there was a cdc
um youtube
post december the 10th of 2020 i believe
it was
right talking about vitamin d in its
correlation with um outcomes
of covid 19 infection and
basically if you're
low status you're more susceptible
okay and to this got cut off there but
the important word there is correlation
there's a lot being looked at with
vitamin d
and covid but i think we have to be
careful about saying that
um supplementation of vitamin d is
protective
or that once in the hospital giving
people vitamin d
helps them recover and one of the real
questions is
um does covid the serious covid deplete
vitamin d
when we find the correlation which is
definitely there
a lot of the people with the most
serious covet cases have low vitamin d
we might jump to a causal relationship
it's conceivable that it's causal but
it's reversed
that one might have normal vitamin d
before getting covered and that falling
to sirius covid depletes vitamin d
that's one possibility which is a
reverse causation
it also may be a correlation without
causation we just have to be careful
it's being studied
and i i want to know more about it but i
don't want to go beyond
what i've read on vitamin d and kovid in
peer-reviewed data
we have a great bonus show for you today
burger king
sent out a tweet that created a real
problem which is women belong in the
kitchen what they meant was
they want more women chefs in the world
it sounded very very different
burger king having to correct the record
alaska has opened covet vaccination to
16 plus
it's incredible what alaska is doing on
vaccination particularly
given how rural much of alaska is and we
will also talk about
the reality of people on unemployment
benefits many on the right believe
people are living the high life on
unemployment benefits including with the
enhanced unemployment provided
through coveted relief uh this is not
the case this is not the case and we
will talk about that
and more on today's bonus show it's
actually a good bonus show today this
one may get an award
which we will give out of course get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming
a member at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
of the people is a new platform matching
local campaigns with supporters and
donors from across the country
sort of like a yelp for local candidates
you can filter by policy and location
and you can support the next generation
of leaders check it out
at of the people.us